wir kommen bei einer neuen sendung von
4cast heute zum thema philosophie und
sitzen ja wie thomas hallo thomas hallo
was ist eigentlich fan fiction ja sein
trikot ist eine literaturgattung und die
hat gewisse probleme wenn man bedenkt
dass nicht alle frei entwickeln auch mit
wissenschaft zu tun hat aber die
historischen ursprünge sind so dass die
science fiction aus einer zeit stammt in
der durch die industrialisierung
insbesondere dass der fortschrittsglaube
der menschen sich stark befördert hatten
und in den industrie romanen des
neunzehnten jahrhunderts da wird in
erster linie die vision transportiert
wie die menschen in der zukunft besser
werden leben können nachdem jetzt eben
die industrialisierung so viel neue
errungenschaften bringt es gibt
allerdings auch in dateien innerhalb der
science fiction bereich der sogenannte
hart science fiction wo auch darauf wert
gelegt wird das ist dass das team an die
dort behandelt werden
auch ganz besonders mit den
errungenschaften der wissenschaften
übereinstimmen so dass also nicht
irgendwelche fantasien ein realistisches
seien eine realistische zahlen zu
herrschen werden man muss vielleicht
noch sagen dass es in den östlichen
ländern im ostblock und in russland
andere formen gibt beziehungsweise dass
da die science fiction einen anderen
namen hat wird von fantastischer
literatur gesprochen aber wir kennen das
auch wir würden sagen fantastische
literatur das ist gewissermaßen der
oberbegriff unter den verschiedenen
genres fantastischen fallen also auch
fantasy oder horrorgeschichten oder so
kannst du einen ganz bedeutenden
schriftsteller science-fiction-literatur
nennen vielleicht den bedeutensten gibt
es da ein das gibt es mit sicherheit
nicht die literatur ist buchstäblich
unübersehbar und es gibt verschiedene
kulturen in der science fiction von
denen ich sagen würde die westliche
hauptsächlich amerikanische kultur ist
sehr stark ausgeprägt aber wir haben
gerade in russland ein ein ungeheuer
weites feld sehr guter science fiction
literatur gerade und vor allem in der
zeit des kalten krieges einflussreichen
vielleicht sagt euch ja der name etwa
dem ziel der eigentlich mehr frage ab
nun ist zwar kein russe war aber der
eben auch in diesem bereich eine ganz
besondere funktion hatte kannst du ein
wichtiges werk von glam auf unserer
zuschauer natürlich sticht auf alle
fälle immer hervor man solar von
stanislaw lem der ist auch deshalb sehr
bekannt weil er es schon zweimal
verfilmt einmal von tarkowski oder esche
verfügung dann aber in neuerer zeit von
soderbergh nächste frage wäre die
inwiefern science fiction mit
philosophie etwas zu tun hat ja das ist
eine interessante sache
mein vorschlag dazu lautet immer science
fiction ist wenn man sie aus einer
bestimmten perspektive betrachtet eine
form von geschichtsphilosophie was heißt
dass das heißt folgendes wenn wir uns
mal überlegen dass auch science fiction
wie alle andere erzählende literatur
erzählt also im erzählen von geschichten
besteht dann müssen wir uns klar machen
dass wir ein zeitproblem haben
der alte schelling und andere haben und
vor allem
der zeit des historismus wurde das
schwer diskutiert bei mäusen zum
beispiel die berühmte dreiheit die
vergangenheit wird erinnert die
gegenwart wird erwägt die zukunft wird
gedacht da sieht man schon ein bisschen
dass problems nämlich anfang von der
zukunft irgend etwas erzählen zu wollen
dann haut das nicht richtig hin können
ich kann immer nur das erzählen an das
ich mich erinnern kann also die zukunft
kann nur gedacht werden im sinne von die
zukunft begegnet uns normalerweise in so
gegenständen wie einem fahrplan oder
einer speisekarte oder so etwas
wir planen aufgrund des studiums der
speisenkarte was wir jetzt in zukunft
essen wollen wir in diesem lokal und
daraus ergibt sich für die science
fiction das problem dass ich für die
zukunft sozusagen ereignisse
konstruieren muss von denen die ich dann
erzähle so als wären sie schon
vorgefahren und das hat noch ein
zusätzliches grundsätzliches problem das
ich mir nicht ereignisse ausdenken kann
die sozusagen tatsächlich in der zukunft
aus stadt gesehen haben stattfinden
werden also kriterien wirklich nicht
wissen kann was in der zukunft passiert
fiktionalität wird damit auf die spitze
getrieben ja und wenn ich nun also sagen
ja das ist kein problem dann muss ich
mir eben eine geschichte ausdenken die
auch jetzt passiert sein könnte und dann
erzähle ich von ihr und versetzen sie
nur die zukunft dann würde man sagen das
ist hauptsächlich wohl der grund warum
die science fiction so schlechte karten
im moment hat
niemand interessiert sich eigentlich
wirklich für science fiction weil alle
die probleme die dort geschildert werden
eigentlich gegenwärtige probleme sind
oder vergangene probleme und wie könnten
wir auch durchaus in anderen schriften
und vergeben fertigen bänden die auf
fremde sterne für gehirn oder so dann
ist das eigentlich eine besondere
attraktion thomas reisenzahn positiv ja
zunächst mal würde ich sagen wenn sein
sich nur darin besteht sich etwas
auszudenken was dann sozusagen künstlich
in die zukunft verlegt wird dann ist das
eigentlich uninteressant literarisch
auch nicht meistens nicht bedeutend wenn
wir uns fragen was science fiction sein
könnte dann müssen wir sehen dass
ausgehend von der idee dass die zukunft
bloß gedacht werden kann wir uns zukunft
ideen vorstellen können
da könnte ich zurückkommen auf diesen
roman solar in der ein gutes beispiel
für gute science fiction ist weil hier
eine frage gestellt wird die in der
gegenwart überhaupt nicht beantwortet
werden kann
wir stellen uns einen planeten vor der
selber so etwas wie ein bewusstsein hat
und der durch seine schöpferische kraft
artefakte zu produzieren in der lage
sein ganzer planet und das ist natürlich
eine vorstellung die sofort dagegen warf
mich ableitbar ist und hier würde man
sagen da hat die science fiction
wirklich ein problem punkt erreicht
sie muss allerdings dass deswegen sage
ich geschichtsphilosophie muss sie
sozusagen ein gedankliches paradigma
schaffen innerhalb dessen solche
theorien dann auch
sinnvoll sein können das sind muss es in
der zukunft seien deswegen muss es in
bestimmten teilen des weltraums sein
ja thomas vielen dank für das interview
wir hoffen mit diesem interview etwas
mehr interesse geweckt zu haben für die
pflanzen schnitt etwas mehr geliebt
vielen dank nochmal thomas und auch
zuschauen wiedersehen bis zum nächsten
vor die bei vielen kassen könnte sein
dass die frau riedel